Since solving this equation is starting to take up some space, I'm just going to
do the rest of our work over here. But know that this is a continuation of the
work that we've been doing over on the left side of the screen. So, I'll
re-write what we had before, 5/3x plus 2 equals 4. We can't deal with this 5/3
yet and we can't get rid of it yet because it's only multiplying x, it's not
multiplying 2 as well. Before we get to that, we need to get rid of the 2. To do
that, we subtract 2 from each side, and then all we need to do is handle this
coefficient. As you've done before, you can either divide by the coefficient
itself, so divide by 5/3. But we know that when you divide by a fraction, it's
the same as multiplying by the reciprocal. So, this is similar to what we talked
about in the previous quiz, where we said that dividing by negative 3 was
equivalent to multiplying by negative 1/3. The same thing is true here, division
by 5/3 is equivalent to multiplication by 3/5. Either way, we'll get rid of the
5/3 in front of the x. And then 2 times 3/5 is just 6/5. And that's our final
answer. x equals 6/5.
Like with all of these problems, we can take 6/5 and substitute it back into the
original equation we had, to check and make sure that both sides of the equation
are actually equal to each other when we apply this condition of x equals 6 over
5.